Andrew Thomas Norway lives in St. Paul, but he's one of those doctors and nurses who flew to New York to help with flood of COVID patients who filled New York hospitals. He's actually at the hospital at Columbia University, where he went to medical school a quarter century ago. At night, after his 12-hour shifts, he sleeps in his old dormitory, literally in the dorm room he had when he was 23. The hospital has scratched out all kinds of extra space for COVID patients, converting 24 operating rooms into intensive care units. But the strangest thing to him?
安德鲁·托马斯·挪威住在圣保罗，但他也是那些飞往纽约帮助应对涌入纽约各家医院的新冠患者的医生和护士之一。他现在就在哥伦比亚大学附属医院，25年前他曾在这里的医学院读书。每天晚上，在12小时的轮班结束后，他就睡在以前的老宿舍里，真的就睡在他23岁时住过的那个房间。医院为新冠患者腾出了各种额外空间，将24间手术室改造成了重症监护室。但对他来说，最奇怪的事情是什么呢？
Normally, there'd be family all over the place. But the families are not able to come close to the hospital. They can't even come in the lobby, let alone get to see the people they love. And the other thing is just the reality that most of these people are going to die in these places alone.
通常情况下，这里到处都会有家属。但家属们无法靠近医院。他们甚至不能进入大厅，更不用说去见他们所爱的人了。而另一件事是，这些人中的大多数注定要独自在这些地方死去。
Most of them are unconscious, in medically-induced comas, because it's easier to survive on a ventilator that way. But because they're unconscious, it means that the gap between these COVID patients and their families is even more profound, because they don't talk on the phone or FaceTime or anything. So Andrew suggested to the nurses that maybe they should take notes each day, little things they notice about each patient to share with the families if the patient dies. I asked him to read a few.
他们中的大多数人都处于昏迷状态，是药物诱导的昏迷，因为那样在呼吸机上更容易存活。但由于他们处于昏迷状态，这意味着这些新冠患者与家人之间的隔阂更加深重，因为他们无法通电话或使用FaceTime等等。因此，安德鲁建议护士们或许应该每天记录下来，记录下他们注意到的关于每位患者的点滴，如果患者去世，可以与家属分享。我请他读了几条。
Sure. This one's from a nurse named Sandy. And she wrote, Mrs-- I won't say the name. "The patient is mostly sleeping. She looks peaceful. Also, I really like her dark green fingernail polish. I would love to know the name of the color."
当然。这一条是一位名叫桑迪的护士写的。她写道，女士——我不会说出名字。“这位病人大部分时间都在睡觉。她看起来很平静。另外，我真的很喜欢她深绿色的指甲油。我很想知道这个颜色的名字。”
Here's another one. "I've been parting the patient's hair to the side. I don't know if that's how he wears it, but I think it looks good that way. Also, yesterday he got a shave, and now he looks so young."
这是另一条。“我一直在把病人的头发分向一边。我不知道他平时是不是这样梳的，但我认为那样看起来不错。还有，昨天他刮了胡子，现在他看起来年轻多了。”
Here's one more. "The patient looks so peaceful. He's sleeping and calm. Everyone is jealous of his salt and pepper hair. He looks like George Clooney right now."
这里还有一条。“这位病人看起来很平静。他正在睡觉，很安详。大家都嫉妒他那花白的头发。他现在看起来就像乔治·克鲁尼。”
I talked to a few of the nurses who are writing these notes, and they said that, because the patients are unconscious, their interactions are pretty basic, so figuring out what to write can be tricky. Dr. Thomas sees that for sure.
我和几位写这些笔记的护士谈过，她们说，因为病人们处于昏迷状态，他们的互动相当有限，所以要找出写什么内容可能会很棘手。托马斯医生当然也看到了这一点。
Yeah, so people end up focusing on what you can see, which is embellishments like earrings and hairstyles and fingernail polish, and also just trying to emphasize that the people are comfortable, that they're sleeping. They're not in pain. That's something we really want to-- almost all the nurses comment on that, it seems, on almost every one.
是的，所以人们最终会关注你能看到的东西，也就是耳环、发型和指甲油等修饰，同时也试图强调人们很舒适，他们正在睡觉。他们没有感到痛苦。这是我们真正想……似乎几乎所有的护士都会在每一条笔记中提到这一点。
And what's your hope about how the families will take this?
对于家属们会如何看待这一点，你有什么期望吗？
My hope is that the families will know that their loved ones were being seen as people and treated as people, and that they weren't alone as this happened.
我的希望是，家属们会知道他们的亲人被当作人来看待，被当作人来关怀，而且在这一切发生时，他们并不孤单。
So they gather details about the people laying in front of them, knowing that there's something like an 80% chance that, if they're on a ventilator with COVID, they won't live. Those are the numbers in New York. Those two things are so different in size, writing down a few tiny observations measured against the enormity of death and what that means. But sometimes, I think that's all you can do. And today on our program, we have two stories where ordinary people rise to this exact task. They look at death standing there-- gigantic, horrifying-- and they say something. And in these stories, truly amazing things happen. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
所以他们收集关于眼前躺着的人的细节，因为他们知道，如果他们因新冠使用呼吸机，他们活下来的几率大概只有80%。这些是纽约的数据。这两件事的量级如此悬殊，写下一些微小的观察结果来衡量死亡的巨大及其背后的意义。但有时，我想这就是你所能做的一切。今天在我们的节目中，我们有两个关于普通人挺身而出完成这一任务的故事。他们注视着死亡——那巨大、可怕的死亡——然后他们发出了声音。而在这些故事中，确实发生了令人惊叹的事情。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Really Long Distance. So remember that tsunami that hit Japan? March 2011, giant black waves more than 30 feet tall hit Japan. A guy in a little town called Otsuchi shot this video. You can hear him yelling. All the houses are washing away.
第一幕，超长距离。还记得那场袭击日本的海啸吗？2011年3月，超过30英尺高的巨大黑色海浪袭击了日本。一个小镇叫大槌町，一个人拍摄了这段视频。你可以听到他在大喊大叫。所有的房子都被冲走了。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Otsuchi had been there for 100 years, and in 30 minutes, it was gone, almost totally flattened. The tsunami and the earthquake that went with it killed six times more people than died in 9/11, over 19,000 people. Another 2,500 are still missing. In the aftermath, of course, families struggled to figure out how they were going to move forward without the people they loved.
大槌町在那里已经有100年的历史了，而在30分钟内，它就消失了，几乎被完全夷为平地。海啸和随之而来的地震造成的死亡人数是“9·11”事件死亡人数的六倍，超过19000人。另有2500人至今下落不明。当然，事后，家庭都在努力寻找如何在没有所爱之人的情况下继续生活下去。
And in that town of Otsuchi, it led to this new-- I don't know, ritual is not exactly the right word for this, but it's something close to that-- this thing that people invented to stay connected to the dead. One of our producers, Miki Meek, has family in Japan, and she grew up going back and forth between there and here. And she watched this documentary about this thing people were doing in Otsuchi on the Japanese News Channel NHK, and got permission for us to play you some excerpts. Here's Miki.
而在大槌町那个小镇，这导致了一种新的——我不知道，仪式这个词用在这里不太准确，但它很接近——人们发明了这种方式来与死者保持联系。我们的一位制片人米基·米克在日本有家人，她从小就在日本和这里之间往返。她在日本新闻频道NHK上看到了关于人们在大槌町所做之事的纪录片，并获得了授权，让我们播放其中的一些片段。接下来是米基。
Of all the areas in Japan affected by the tsunami, Otsuchi has one of the highest numbers of missing people, 421. Today, it's still partly in ruins, and partly a construction site, as they try to rebuild the town on higher ground. But a year before the tsunami happened, this guy named Itaru Sasaki, he was already dealing with a loss. His cousin had just died, and Itaru was having a hard time figuring out how to talk about it.
在日本所有受海啸影响的地区中，大槌町的失踪人数最多，为421人。今天，它仍然部分处于废墟之中，部分是建筑工地，因为他们试图在更高的地方重建小镇。但在海啸发生前一年，这个叫佐佐木格的人，已经在应对失去亲人的痛苦。他的堂弟刚刚去世，佐佐木正努力克服如何谈论这件事。
So he did something pretty ingenious. He went out and bought an old-fashioned phone booth and stuck it in his garden. It looks like an old English-style one. It's square and painted white, and has these glass window panes. Inside is a black rotary phone rusting on a wood shelf. This phone connected to nowhere. It didn't work at all. But that didn't matter to Itaru. He just needed a place where he felt like he could talk to his cousin, a place where he could air out his grief. And so putting an old phone booth in his garden, which sits on this little windy hill overlooking the Pacific Ocean, it felt like a perfect solution.
所以他做了一件非常巧妙的事。他出去买了一个老式的电话亭，把它放在了花园里。它看起来像那种老式的英式电话亭。它是方形的，漆成白色，有玻璃窗格。里面是一部锈迹斑斑的黑色转盘电话，架在木架子上。这部电话连接着虚无。它根本无法使用。但这对佐佐木来说并不重要。他只是需要一个地方，让他觉得可以和堂弟交谈，一个可以发泄悲伤的地方。因此，把一个旧电话亭放在他花园里，坐落在俯瞰太平洋的小山坡上，这感觉像是一个完美的解决方案。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
He's saying, because my thoughts could not be relayed over a regular phone line, I wanted them to be carried on the wind.
他说，因为我的思念无法通过普通的电话线路传达，我希望它们能被风带走。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
So I named it the Wind Telephone, [JAPANESE]. The idea of keeping up a relationship with the dead is not such a strange one in Japan. The line between our world and their world is thin. Lots of families keep a Buddhist altar for their dead relatives in the living room. My uncle has one for our family. There are photos on a little platform, and every day he leaves fresh fruit and rice for them, lights incense, and rings a bell. It's a way to stay in touch, to let them know that there's still a big part of our family.
所以我把它命名为“风之电话”。在日本，与死者保持关系的想法并不奇怪。我们世界与他们世界之间的界限很薄。许多家庭在客厅里为死去的亲人供奉着佛教祭坛。我叔叔家里就有一个。在一个小平台上摆放着照片，他每天都会为他们供奉新鲜的水果和米饭，点上香，敲响铃铛。这是一种保持联系的方式，让他们知道他们仍然是我们家庭的重要组成部分。
So after the tsunami and earthquake happened, word got out about Itaru's special Wind Telephone, that he was using it as another way to stay connected to the dead. Soon, people started showing up randomly on his property and walking right into the phone booth. This has been going on for five years now. Itaru estimates that thousands of people from all over Japan have come to use his phone. A TV station asked Itaru and the people who come to use his phone if they could videotape their calls from a distance and put an audio recorder in the phone booth. They wanted to get a sense of how people are still grieving.
所以海啸和地震发生后，关于佐佐木特别的“风之电话”的消息传开了，人们知道他正在用它作为与死者保持联系的另一种方式。很快，人们开始随机出现在他的土地上，直接走进电话亭。这种情况已经持续五年了。佐佐木估计，来自日本各地的数千人已经来使用过他的电话。一家电视台询问佐佐木和那些来用电话的人，是否可以从远处录制他们的通话，并在电话亭里放置一个录音机。他们想了解人们是如何在悲伤中坚持生活的。
I watched their documentary after the fifth anniversary of the tsunami back in March. That whole week, all the news programs in Japan were airing memorial programs. But I found the calls in this particular program remarkable and moving for just how simple they were. One woman from Otsuchi, named Sachiko Okawa, showed up one afternoon. She's 71 years old, and lost her husband in the tsunami. She regularly brings her two young grandsons to the phone booth, and you can tell by how casually they talked to him on the phone. They squish into the phone booth with their grandma, wearing matching blue and black striped shirts. Sachiko starts the call by picking up the receiver and saying hello.
在三月份海啸五周年纪念日之后，我观看了他们的纪录片。那一整周，日本所有的电视节目都在播放纪念活动。但我发现这个特定节目中的通话非常引人注目和感人，仅仅是因为它们是如此简单。一位来自大槌町、名叫大川幸子的女士，一个下午出现在那里。她71岁，在海啸中失去了丈夫。她经常带着两个年幼的孙子来到电话亭，你可以从他们在大电话时随意的语气中看出。他们穿着蓝黑相间的条纹衫，和祖母一起挤进电话亭。大川幸子拿起听筒，说了声你好，开始了通话。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Her oldest grandson quickly jumps in.
她的大孙子很快插话。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Hi, Grandpa.
爷爷，你好。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
How are you?
你好吗？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
I'll be in fourth grade next semester. Wasn't that fast?
下学期我就要上四年级了。时间过得真快，不是吗？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Daina, my younger brother, he'll be in second grade next year. Then Sachiko corrects him. She says, no, Daina will be in second grade this year, not next.
戴纳，我的弟弟，他明年上二年级。然后大川幸子纠正了他。她说，不对，戴纳今年上二年级，不是明年。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Yeah, yeah, this year. A lot of calls were just like this, straightforward updates about life, the kind of quick highlights reel you might give to any family member you were catching up with on the phone. The boy, he then tells his grandpa--
是的，是的，今年。很多通话都是这样的，关于生活的简单更新，就像你打电话给任何一个家庭成员聊近况时那种简短的要点回顾。男孩然后告诉他的爷爷——
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Grandma is fine, too.
奶奶也很好。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
I'm giving the phone to Daina now. Daina, his little brother, grabs the phone.
我现在把电话给戴纳。戴纳，他的小弟弟，抢过了电话。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Grandpa, I finished all my homework. Sachiko urges him to keep talking.
爷爷，我做完了所有的作业。大川幸子催促他继续说。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
He says, everyone is doing fine. Then he hangs up. They all say goodbye.
他说，大家都很好。然后他挂了电话。他们都说了再见。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉对话]
Bye bye.
再见。
As they're walking out of the booth, Daina says--
当他们走出电话亭时，戴纳说——
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Maybe Grandpa will say he heard us.
也许爷爷会说他听到了我们的话。
In another call, a woman in a puffy winter jacket with a fur-lined hood shows up at the booth by herself. Her name is Kikue Hirano, and she's 66. She used to live in Otsuchi, but she moved away after she lost her house and her husband in the tsunami. Her husband was a deep sea fisherman. His name was Miyoji and they used to talk and drink sake together at night. Now, Kikue lives alone, about 50 miles away. But sometimes Kikue finds herself driving back to Otsuchi, and to this booth. I watched her do this thing that a lot of callers seemed to do. You hear Kikue actually dialing the rotary phone, saying some numbers to herself.
在另一次通话中，一位穿着毛领连帽羽绒服的女士独自来到电话亭。她的名字叫平野菊江，今年66岁。她曾经住在大槌町，但在海啸中失去家园和丈夫后搬走了。她的丈夫是一名深海渔民。他的名字叫美代治，他们过去常在晚上一起喝酒聊天。现在，菊江一个人住在50英里外的地方。但有时菊江会发现自己开车回到大槌町，回到这个电话亭。我看着她做着许多打电话的人似乎都会做的事情。你听到菊江实际上在拨动转盘电话，嘴里自言自语说着数字。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
4, 2, 5, 7, 4, 4. She's dialing the phone number for her old house in Otsuchi, the last place she knew to reach her husband. Then Kikue just stands in the booth in silence, holding the phone to her ear.
4、2、5、7、4、4。她正在拨打她在旧大槌町家的号码，那是她最后知道能联系上她丈夫的地方。然后菊江只是静静地站在电话亭里，把电话贴在耳边。
Sometimes she fidgets around, and tilts her head up and concentrates on the ceiling, the same way I do when I want to cry but I'm trying hard not to. It doesn't work. Kikue brushes some tears off her face. Eventually, she hangs up. She lingers in the booth a little longer, hands clasped together in front of her, staring at the phone booth floor. She walks out.
有时她会烦躁不安，抬头看向天花板，集中精神，这和我想要哭却努力忍住时的样子一样。但这没用。菊江擦掉脸上的泪水。最终，她挂断了电话。她在电话亭里又逗留了一会儿，双手合十在身前，盯着电话亭的地板。她走了出去。
One pattern that the owner of the phone booth, Itaru, has noticed over the years is that more men than women come to use it. Not surprisingly, this is not a demographic that's known for sharing their feelings, especially the older farmers. They already have a reputation for not talking much. In one of the phone calls recorded in winter, a man with gray hair and a little towel hanging around his neck walks into the garden. This kind of towel is part of the uniform of Japanese farmers. They use them to wipe away sweat and clean their hands. This man opens the telephone booth door, and under his breath, you hear him say--
电话亭主人佐佐木多年来注意到的一个模式是，男性比女性更多地来使用它。不出所料，这并不是一个以分享感受著称的群体，尤其是老农民。他们已经以不爱说话而闻名。在冬季录下的一通电话中，一个脖子上围着小毛巾、头发花白的男人走进花园。这种毛巾是日本农民制服的一部分。他们用它擦汗和清洁双手。这个男人打开电话亭的门，你可以听到他压低声音说——
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Huh, so this is the Wind Telephone. This appears to be his very first visit to the phone booth. He lost his oldest son in the tsunami. His son's name was Nobuyuki. He also lost his house and had to move into temporary housing with his wife. And recently, she got sick and also passed away. He calls her okaasan. It means mom in Japanese. It's what everyone in the family calls a female head of the house, even the husband. It's a very intimate, loving term.
哼，这就是“风之电话”啊。这似乎是他第一次造访电话亭。他在海啸中失去了长子。他儿子的名字叫信之。他还失去了房子，不得不和妻子住进临时住房。最近，她生病去世了。他称呼她为“妈妈”。这是日语里的“妈妈”。这是家里每个人对女性家长的称呼，甚至连丈夫也这样叫。这是一个非常亲密、充满爱意的称呼。
[ROTARY DIALING]
[转盘拨号声]
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Hello?
喂？
Nobuyuki.
信之。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Is Mom with you?
妈妈和你在一起吗？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Sorry to ask this, but take care of her, and your grandma and grandpa, too.
对不起，请多关照她，还有你的爷爷奶奶，也拜托了。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Mom?
妈妈？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
I'll come again, OK?
我还会再来的，好吗？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Mom--
妈妈——
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
--I'll be back.
——我会回来的。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Bye.
再见。
He uses the towel around his neck to wipe his eyes.
他用脖子上的毛巾擦了擦眼睛。
One of the things that makes these calls so poignant to me is all the understated ways that people are actually saying I love you and I miss you. I'd never say something so direct like that in Japanese. It's just not done. I've only seen people say it in the soap operas. [JAPANESE]. Even saying that right now feels weird. I've never said that to my mom or my grandparents.
这些通话让我感到如此辛酸的一点是，人们实际上在以各种低调的方式表达“我爱你”和“我想你”。在日语中，我永远不会说得那么直接。根本不会这样做。我只在肥皂剧中见过人们那样说。[日语]。即使现在说出来也感觉很奇怪。我从来没有对我妈妈或爷爷奶奶说过。
[CREAKING]
[吱呀声]
Take this call. It's winter. The phone booth is surrounded by snow.
接听这一通。那是冬天。电话亭被白雪覆盖。
[ROTARY DIALING]
[转盘拨号声]
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Hello?
喂？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Mom?
妈妈？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Where are you? He's an older man wearing a baseball cap. He also calls his wife Mom. His wife, daughter and mother, they all went missing in the tsunami.
你在哪里？他是一位戴着棒球帽的老人。他也称呼妻子为“妈妈”。他的妻子、女儿和母亲，都在海啸中失踪了。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
It's so cold, but you're not getting cold, are you?
天气很冷，但你不冷吧？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Are grandma and our daughter Miyuki with you, too?
奶奶和我们的女儿美雪也和你在一起吗？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Come back soon.
快回来吧。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Be found soon. Everyone is waiting for you.
快被找到吧。大家都在等你。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
OK?
好吗？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Be found soon. Hurry home, OK?
快回来吧。赶快回家，好吗？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
I'll build a house in the same place.
我会在同一个地方建一栋房子。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Eat something, anything.
吃点东西，什么都行。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Just be alive. Somewhere, anywhere.
只要活着就好。在什么地方都行，在哪都行。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
I'm so lonely.
我好寂寞。
He never says I love you directly. Real feelings are communicated through small gestures, especially ones of concern, like when he asks his wife, are you staying warm? Are you eating? And then promising, I'll build a house for us. These are total heartfelt declarations of love.
他从不直接说“我爱你”。真实的感受是通过微小的举动传达的，特别是那些关心的细节，比如当他问妻子：你冷吗？你吃了吗？然后承诺说：我会为我们建一栋房子。这些都是发自内心的深爱宣言。
For other men, the phone booth is a place where they can finally say their complicated feelings out loud. They can voice their regrets. Anyone who's had someone close to them die knows this feeling. Like, I've kept having the same one-way conversation with my dad in my head ever since he passed away last year. I just keep telling him all the situations where I wish I had been kinder, more patient. One call I watched was from a young father with rectangle glasses and a long black jacket. He lost his family, both parents, his wife-- her name was Mine-- and a one-year-old son named Issei.
对于其他男人来说，电话亭是一个他们终于可以大声说出复杂情绪的地方。他们可以吐露遗憾。任何有过亲近之人去世经历的人都知道这种感觉。就像，自从我父亲去年去世后，我脑海中一直进行着同样的单向对话。我只是不停地告诉他，我真希望在那些情况下自己能更友善、更耐心一些。我看到的其中一通通话来自一位戴着长方形眼镜、穿着黑色长外套的年轻父亲。他失去了全家，父母双亡，妻子——她的名字叫美乃——还有一个一岁的儿子叫一诚。
[ROTARY DIALING]
[转盘拨号声]
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Dad?
爸爸？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Mom?
妈妈？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Mine.
美乃。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Issei.
一诚。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
It's already been five years since the disaster.
灾难发生已经五年了。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
If this voice reaches you, please listen.
如果这声音能传到你们那里，请听一听。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Sometimes I don't know what I'm living for.
有时我不知道我是为了什么而活。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Issei, please let me hear you call me Papa.
一诚，请让我听听你叫我爸爸。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Even though I built a new house--
虽然我建了新房子——
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
--Dad, Mom--
——爸爸、妈妈——
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
--Mine and Issei--
——美乃和一诚——
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
--without all of you, it's meaningless.
——没有你们所有人，这一切都毫无意义。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
I want to hear your reply, but I can't hear anything.
我想听你们的回应，但我什么都听不到。
He hangs up the phone, takes off his glasses, and covers his eyes with his hands.
他挂断电话，摘下眼镜，用双手捂住眼睛。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
I'm sorry.
对不起。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
I'm so sorry I couldn't save you.
真的很对不起，我没能救你们。
[CREAKING]
[吱呀声]
[DOOR SHUTTING]
[门关上的声音]
There's a couple of phrases I heard callers tell the dead again and again-- [JAPANESE], don't worry about us, and [JAPANESE], which basically means I'm doing my very best. I'm enduring. In Japan, [JAPANESE] is a catch-all slogan for slogging through life's many challenges, no matter how tiny or big. From trying to pass a test at school to grieving, you hear it all the time, for everything. In the phone booth, [JAPANESE] and [JAPANESE], these are key phrases to reassure the dead that the living, the people left behind, they're doing OK, even if they're not.
我听到来访者反复对死者说的一对短语是——[日语]，别担心我们，还有[日语]，这基本上意味着我正在尽我所能。我在忍耐。在日本，[日语]是应对生活诸多挑战的一句万能口号，无论挑战是大是小。从考试到悲伤，你到处都能听到它。在电话亭里，[日语]和[日语]，这些是安慰死者的关键短语，告诉生者，那些留下来的人，他们过得还好，即使实际上并非如此。
People don't want to worry or burden their loved ones, even dead loved ones, because most Japanese are Buddhist, and generally believe that, when someone dies, they're not suddenly relieved of all their earthly concerns. They're not automatically in heaven, happy and carefree. Many people believe that, if the dead see a family member suffering, they can't let go of their earthly life. They hesitate to cross to the other side, and end up stuck in a no man's land.
人们不想让亲人感到担忧或增加负担，即使是已经死去的亲人，因为大多数日本人信奉佛教，普遍认为当一个人去世时，他们并没有立即解除世俗的烦恼。他们不会自动进入天堂，变得快乐无忧。许多人相信，如果死者看到家人遭受痛苦，他们就无法放下世俗生活。他们会犹豫是否要走向彼岸，最终陷入无主之地的困境。
I heard these reassurances in a call from a 15-year-old kid named Ren Kozaki to his dad. He arrived at the phone booth after spending four hours on public transportation by himself. Ren lives in a city much farther north that wasn't affected as much by the tsunami, but his dad was a truck driver who drove all over Japan, and in a last-minute schedule change, he got sent on a route that took him along the coast when the tsunami hit. He's been missing ever since. Ren went into the phone booth wearing a red backpack. And what he does in his call, you hear him signaling to his dad that it's OK, he should keep moving on into the afterworld.
我从一个名叫小崎莲的15岁孩子打给父亲的电话中听到了这些安慰。他在独自乘坐四小时公共交通工具后到达了电话亭。莲住在一个更北部的城市，那里受海啸的影响没那么大，但他父亲是一名卡车司机，足迹遍布全日本，由于最后一刻的时间表变动，他被派往了海啸发生时经过沿海的路线。从那以后他就失踪了。莲背着一个红色背包走进了电话亭。在通话中，你可以听到他向父亲示意一切都好，他应该继续前往彼岸。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Dad?
爸爸？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
The four of us are doing fine.
我们四个都过得很好。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
We're [JAPANESE].
我们正在[日语]。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
You don't need to worry about us. [JAPANESE].
你不需要担心我们。[日语]。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Dad, are you doing OK?
爸爸，你还好吗？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
I do have one question I want to ask you.
我有一个问题想问你。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Why did you die?
为什么你会死？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Why did it have to be you, Dad?
为什么偏偏是你，爸爸？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Why just me?
为什么是我？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
I've always wondered--
我一直想知道——
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
--why am I the only one who is--
——为什么只有我是——
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
--different from everyone else. Anyways--
——和大家都不一样。不管怎样——
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
--please be found quickly.
——请快点被找到吧。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Where are you now?
你现在在哪里？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
They never found anything of you.
他们什么都没找到你的。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
I wanted to talk with you again.
我想再和你谈谈。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Ren left the booth. In late February, he came back with his entire family-- his mom, younger brother, and sister. They all drove down to Otsuchi together. And when they got to the phone booth, at first they kind of awkwardly hung out in front of it. So to break the ice, Ren walks in and places the first call to their dad. He tells him--
莲离开了电话亭。二月下旬，他带着全家回来——妈妈、弟弟和妹妹。他们一起开车来到大槌町。当他们到达电话亭时，起初他们尴尬地站在前面。为了打破僵局，莲走了进去，打出了给父亲的第一通电话。他告诉他——
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
--I brought everyone with me today.
——今天我把大家都带过来了。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Bye.
再见。
When Ren walks out, his family laughs. They say--
当莲走出来时，家人笑了。他们说——
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
That was so fast. Ren shoots back--
这也太快了吧。莲反驳道——
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
--it was just a quick report to dad that I brought everyone with me today. Next up are Ren's little brother and sister, who are 12 and 14 years old. They go into the booth together, and the sister is talking and laughing nervously.
——这只是快速汇报一下爸爸，我今天把大家都带来了。接下来是莲的弟弟和妹妹，他们分别是12岁和14岁。他们一起走进电话亭，妹妹紧张地边说边笑。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
What am I supposed to say? What should I tell them?
我该说些什么？我该告诉他们什么？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Wait, wait, wait. Don't leave me alone in here. The sister picks up the phone. And let me just say, the mom told the film crew that this is a girl who has not said a single word about her dad to anyone since he went missing five years ago. So she picks up the phone and starts to cry.
等等，等等，等等。别把我一个人留在里面。妹妹拿起电话。我想说的是，妈妈告诉摄制组，这是一个自父亲五年前失踪后，就从未对任何人提起过父亲的女孩。所以她拿起电话开始哭泣。
[SOBS]
[哭泣声]
She asks her brother again, what should I talk to him about? Her little brother's name is Riku, and he tells her--
她又问她哥哥，我该和他说些什么？她的小弟弟叫陆，他告诉她——
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Say what you wanted to tell him.
说说你当时想告诉他的话吧。
[SOBS]
[哭泣声]
She says, are you trying to make me laugh, Riku? Riku says--
她说，你是想逗我笑吗，陆？陆说——
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
--no, I'm not. Then she finally starts talking to her dad. The conversation is all over the place. And she's crying so hard she can barely talk.
——没有，我没有。然后她终于开始对父亲说话。谈话很杂乱。她哭得太厉害，几乎无法开口。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Dad, I'm so sorry I always used to say you were stinky. What happened to your promise to buy me a violin? Now I'll have to buy one myself.
爸爸，对不起，以前我总说你臭。你答应给我买的小提琴呢？现在我得自己买了。
Her little brother who sticks close to her, he encourages her to keep going. He says, what else? So she tells her dad--
一直紧贴着她的小弟弟鼓励她继续说。他说，还有呢？所以她告诉父亲——
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
I started tennis in junior high school. I'm not in the top eight. I want to be in the top eight in our last tournament. Please cheer for me.
我在初中开始打网球了。我没进前八名。我希望能在我们最后一场比赛中进前八。请为我加油。
I got hooked on this boy band, The Johnnys, when I was in my first year of junior high. I'm still hooked. They both say--
我在读初一的时候迷上了一个男孩乐队“The Johnnys”。我现在还迷着呢。他们俩都说——
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
--goodbye. They come out of the booth together. Now it's their mom's turn. Her kids tell her itterasshai.
——再见。他们一起走出了电话亭。现在轮到妈妈了。孩子们对她说“一路走好”。
Itterasshai.
一路走好。
Have a good trip. Good luck. Ren, the oldest, he bows and waves to her. She walks in, picks up the phone, and lets out a big sigh.
旅途平安。祝你好运。莲，作为老大，他鞠躬向她挥手。她走进去，拿起电话，深深地叹了一口气。
[SIGHS]
[叹气声]
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Where should I start?
我该从哪儿开始呢？
[SIGHS]
[叹气声]
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
I feel like you're still alive somewhere. We had so many things we wanted to do together.
我觉得你还在某个地方活着。我们还有好多事想一起做。
[SNIFFS]
[吸鼻涕声]
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Over the phone we always said to each other, are you alive? Yes, I'm alive. It was our password between the two of us, wasn't it? I can't ask you that anymore.
以前打电话时我们总是对彼此说，你还活着吗？是的，我活着。那是我们之间的暗号，对吧？我不能再那样问你了。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Come back. We, all four of us together, we will be waiting. Bye.
回来吧。我们四个，都会等你。再见。
[PHONE HANGING UP]
[电话挂断声]
After she comes out, the family lingers outside the phone booth for a while.
她出来后，全家在电话亭外徘徊了一会儿。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
This was literally the first time they'd all talked about their dad together since the tsunami happened five years ago. The youngest, Riku, he sat quietly on a bench with his head in his hands. The night before his dad disappeared, they went to a public bath together. His mom and older siblings tell him--
这实际上是自海啸发生五年来，他们第一次一起谈论父亲。最小的陆，安静地坐在长椅上，双手抱头。父亲失踪的前一天晚上，他们一起去了公共浴室。妈妈和年长的孩子对他说——
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
--Riku, you don't need to keep your feelings in. Go ahead and cry when you want to. Ren, the oldest, gently teases him. He says--
——陆，不需要把感情憋在心里。想哭的时候就哭吧。莲，作为老大，温柔地打趣他。他说——
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
--see, he can't stop crying. Mom says yeah, but he held back until now. It's OK because you held back. You endured until now.
——看，他哭个不停。妈妈说，是啊，但他一直忍到现在。没关系，因为你忍住了。你坚持到现在。
The sister then hands Riku her handkerchief. The mom says to her kids, we were all about to fall apart. We were so broken. We didn't think we could make it through. And maybe that's why we never talked about Dad until now. But talking to him on the phone today, it changed something.
妹妹然后把手帕递给陆。妈妈对孩子们说，我们当时都快崩溃了。我们伤透了心。我们以为我们挺不过去了。也许这就是为什么我们直到今天才提起爸爸。但今天在电话里和他交谈，改变了一些东西。
Miki Meek is one of the producers of our program. Thanks to Tomohiko Yokoyama and NHK Sendai, who recorded all this and shared it with us. Today's show is mostly a rerun. We checked this week, and the wind phone is still in operation, though not many visitors right now because of COVID. The Japanese government is asking people to stay home.
米基·米克是我们节目的制片人之一。感谢横山智彦和NHK仙台，他们录下了这一切并与我们分享。今天的节目大多是重播。我们这周查过，风之电话还在运营中，虽然因为新冠疫情现在来访者不多。日本政府正在呼吁人们居家。
Coming up, two brothers in their 80s have a last chance to talk to each other before they die, and neither wants to take it. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，一对80多岁的兄弟在去世前有最后一次交流的机会，但谁都不想抓住它。芝加哥公共广播将在节目继续时带来这部分内容。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, One Last Thing Before I Go, stories that are about-- well, they're about what power do words have in the face of death?
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是“我离开前的最后一件事”，讲述的是——嗯，是关于在死亡面前语言拥有什么力量？
We've arrived at Act Two of our program-- Act Two, Uncle's Keeper.
我们已经到了节目的第二幕——第二幕，叔叔的守护者。
So in the first act of our program, people kind of defy death by making small talk and some talk that was not so small with their dead relatives. In this act, somebody wants to do something very similar, make a connection that seemed impossible between people. Except in this story, all the relatives are alive, which you'd think would make it super easy. The story comes from Jonathan Goldstein.
在节目的第一幕中，人们通过与已故亲人的闲聊，甚至是一些意义重大的交谈，挑战了死亡。在这一幕中，有人想要做非常相似的事情，在人与人之间建立看似不可能的联系。除了在这个故事里，所有的亲戚都还活着，你可能会认为这会让事情变得超级简单。这个故事来自乔纳森·戈尔茨坦。
Hello?
喂？
Hey, Dad?
嘿，爸？
Hi, Johnny.
嘿，乔尼。
Hey. How you doing?
嘿。你好吗？
Good, you?
挺好，你呢？
Good, good. Good Yuntif.
挺好，挺好。祝节日快乐。
Shana Tova.
新年快乐。
[HEBREW]
[希伯来语]
[HEBREW]. [CHUCKLES] What's that mean?
[希伯来语]。[轻笑]那是什么意思？
I'm not sure.
我不确定。
Oh, oh.
哦，哦。
This is my father, Buzz. I'm calling him at his home in Montreal. And the reason we're talking crazy talk is because it's Yom Kippur, the Jewish day of atonement, which seems as good a day as any to talk with him about forgiveness.
这是我的父亲，巴兹。我正在打给他在蒙特利尔的家。我们说些乱七八糟的话是因为今天是赎罪日，犹太人的忏悔日，这似乎是和他讨论宽恕的好日子。
So I wanted to-- I wanted to ask you something, and I just wanted to gauge your interest.
所以我想要——我想要问你一件事，我只是想试探一下你的兴趣。
Yeah.
嗯。
How would you feel about paying your brother, Sheldon, a visit?
你觉得去探望一下你弟弟谢尔顿怎么样？
I have no feelings about it. I'm not really interested.
我对此没什么感觉。我不怎么感兴趣。
You're not?
不感兴趣？
No.
不。
My father, Buzz, is 80, and his brother, Sheldon, his only sibling, is 85. And for the past 40 years, they've pretty much been on the outs. My father lives in Montreal, and Sheldon lives in Florida. And the last time they saw each other, over 20 years ago, was at their mother's funeral when they had a fight over the details of the arrangement. Since then, they've hardly spoken.
我的父亲巴兹今年80岁，他的弟弟谢尔顿，也就是他唯一的兄弟，今年85岁。过去40年里，他们几乎一直处于断联状态。我父亲住在蒙特利尔，谢尔顿住在佛罗里达。他们最后一次见面是在20多年前母亲的葬礼上，当时他们因为安排细节发生了争吵。从那以后，他们几乎没怎么说过话。
It worries me because there's not a lot of time left, and I don't want my father to have regrets. And my father has a profound capacity for regret. My mother gave up trying to reunite them years ago after many attempts. So I know that if I don't push him, no one else will.
这让我担心，因为没剩多少时间了，我不希望父亲留下遗憾。而我的父亲有着强烈的遗憾倾向。我母亲多年来经过多次尝试后放弃了撮合他们。所以我知道，如果我不推动他，就没有别人会做了。
I'm not surprised that you're not jumping at the idea, but I'm a little surprised--
我不惊讶你没有对这个想法表现出极大的热情，但我有一点点惊讶——
No.
不。
--that you're as against the idea.
——你会如此反对这个想法。
Yeah. Time's passed. He hasn't shown much interest. So I'm respecting that, and I leave him alone.
嗯。时间过了很久。他没表现出太大的兴趣。所以我尊重这一点，我就不再打扰他了。
What he did do was he called you on your 80th birthday not so long ago, and you felt good about that.
他确实在不久前你的80岁生日时打过电话给你，你感觉挺好。
Yeah, because I called him on his 80th birthday.
嗯，因为我在他80岁生日时打给了他。
This kind of tit for tat accounting is what always gets in the way.
这种斤斤计较的态度总是横亘在中间。
You know what it is at this point with him? I'll tell you what it is. I don't think it's even anger. He's past anger. And he's past any feelings of animosity. He's pissed. He just doesn't care.
你知道他在这一点上是怎么想的吗？我告诉你吧。我想那甚至不是愤怒。他已经过了愤怒的阶段。他已经没有了任何敌意。他是厌烦了。他只是不在乎。
Yeah.
嗯。
That's apathy. I mean, sometimes at least hate or love, they're emotions. Apathy is nothing.
那是冷漠。我是说，有时候至少恨或爱，它们都是情感。冷漠意味着什么都没有。
Yeah.
嗯。
You know what, Johnny? As a child, even when I was 10, when I was nine and eight, I was crazy about him. We had a great-- I loved him. He was the older brother. He would-- hello?
你知道吗，乔尼？小时候，哪怕在我10岁，9岁和8岁的时候，我都很迷他。我们有一段很棒的——我爱他。他是哥哥。他会——喂？
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I'm listening.
在，在，在。我在听。
I just looked up to him. And he had all the friends. Sometimes he'd take me along with him. And he was [INAUDIBLE]. Somebody tried to call here, dinging me here.
我刚才崇拜他。他有很多朋友。有时候他会带上我。他当时是[听不清]。有人想打进来，在这响个不停。
The most complicated question, the one I keep coming back to, is how did the bad blood begin? And there are many versions-- an ill-fated trip to Montreal where Sheldon felt slighted about having to stay in my father's basement, an ill-fated trip to New York where my father felt slighted about having to stay in Sheldon's attic, rude words spoken to each other's wives. In one version of the story, Sheldon's refusal to bring a table to my bris almost resulted in my being circumcised on an ironing board. But in the version being told today, my father was asked by Sheldon to pay more than his fair share for their mother's funeral.
最复杂的问题，也是我不断回来的问题，是这些积怨是怎么开始的？有很多版本——一次去蒙特利尔的不幸旅行，谢尔顿觉得必须住在父亲地下室里受到了冷落；一次去纽约的不幸旅行，父亲觉得必须住在谢尔顿阁楼里受到了冷落；对彼此的妻子说了粗鲁的话。在一个版本的故事里，谢尔顿拒绝为我的割礼仪式准备一张桌子，差点导致我只能在熨衣板上进行手术。但在今天讲述的版本里，父亲被谢尔顿要求支付超过他份额的母亲葬礼费用。
And I said, you're always working some kind of an angle. So then he got furious. He got furious. He started screaming at the phone, go to hell, drop dead, blah, blah, blah.
我说，你总是带着某种目的。于是他火冒三丈。他火冒三丈。他在电话那头尖叫着，下地狱去吧，去死吧，等等等等。
That was how that ended. But I feel he's the kind of guy-- he has angles like that. He has angles. I always felt I was on the up and up with him, and he wasn't with me.
这就是那样结束的。但我感觉他就是那种人——他总带着那样的算计。他总是有算计。我一直觉得自己对他诚心诚意，而他却不是。
If you got a stronger sense that he was interested in seeing you, then would you--
如果你能有更强的感觉他想见你，那么你会——
Yes, yes.
会，会。
--you would be more inclined to see him?
——你会更有兴趣见他？
I wouldn't stay at his house though. That's out of the question.
不过我不会住在他家里。那是不可能的。
OK, quick sidebar-- anytime I've ever raised the prospect of visiting Sheldon, no matter how hypothetical the scenario, my father always makes a point of insisting how no matter what he would not stay in Sheldon's house, even if he was invited to, which, I should point out, he never is.
OK，快速侧记一下——不管我什么时候提起探望谢尔顿的可能性，无论场景多么假设性，我父亲总是强调无论如何他都不会住进谢尔顿家里，即使他受邀——我应该指出，他从来没有受到邀请。
I wouldn't stay at his house.
我不会住在他家。
How come you-- [LAUGHS]
你怎么总——[笑]
I wouldn't stay there. I mean, that's not my thing.
我不会住在那里。我是说，那不是我的风格。
How come you always bring that up? I mean, normally--
你怎么总提这事？我是说，通常——
Of course. I don't feel comfortable.
当然。我不觉得舒服。
--when someone goes to visit someone that they haven't seen in decades, they'll stay at a hotel.
——当一个人去探望几十年没见的人时，他们会住在旅馆。
I would stay at a motel or somewhere near his place.
我会住在汽车旅馆或是他附近的地方。
A motel. Yeah. No, we'd get a place with an ice machine and, you know.
汽车旅馆。好的。我们会找个带制冰机的，你知道的。
Why? You're interested in making a trip?
为什么？你有兴趣去旅行？
[SIGHS] I mean, I'm interested-- do you think that there's anything to be gained in seeing him?
[叹气]我是说，我有兴趣——你觉得见他会有什么收获吗？
Hm. I guess there's something. You know, you share your common experience, and you talk about the old days, and there are things that only he and I can remember.
嗯。我想会有一些。你知道，你们分享共同的经历，谈论过去的日子，有些东西只有我和他能记得。
Yeah.
嗯。
What you could do is you could call him and see what his attitude is. It depends on how you feel, what kind of reception you get.
你可以做的是打给他，看看他的态度。取决于你的感觉，取决于你得到什么样的回应。
Yeah. I mean, I would. I would be happy to do that. My concern is that--
嗯。我是说，我会的。我很高兴这样做。我的担忧是——
I like your initial suggestion that you call and feel him out, see what he's like.
我喜欢你最初的建议，打给他试探一下，看他是什么态度。
OK, I didn't suggest that, but-- you suggested that.
OK，我没那样建议，但——是你建议的。
Yeah, I like that. But you'll give me an honest reaction.
嗯，我喜欢那样。但你会给我一个真实的反应。
I'm happy to do it, but-- I mean, what are you looking for from-- what do you want to hear from him?
我很乐意做，但——我是说，你从——你想从他那里听到什么？
I miss my brother. I would like to see him.
我想念我的弟弟。我想见见他。
OK.
OK。
That's all.
就是这样。
OK.
OK。
You understand? And you come back on me with an honest evaluation.
你明白吗？你回来给我一个诚实的评估。
[DIAL TONE]
[拨号音]
Hello?
喂？
Sheldon?
谢尔顿？
Yes, speaking.
是的，请讲。
Hi.
嘿。
That was quite a shock getting your phone call. You said Jon, and I--
接到你的电话真是太震惊了。你说乔恩，我——
Yeah.
嗯。
My hearing is not that great.
我的听力不太好。
OK.
OK。
And when I heard the first message I'm saying, who the heck is that? I don't know anybody by that name.
当我听到第一条留言时，我说，那个人到底是谁？我不认识那个名字的人。
Sheldon now lives outside of Fort Lauderdale, but my few memories of him are from when he lived in upstate New York. I remember he lived in a trailer. I remember that he worked at a local prison, that he smoked cigars, that he looked a little like my father, but was hunched like the world was weighing down on him. And he always wore this expression on his face that seemed to say, you got to be kidding me.
谢尔顿现在住在劳德代尔堡郊外，但我对他为数不多的记忆来自于他住在美国北部的时候。我记得他住在一个拖车里。我记得他在当地监狱工作，他抽雪茄，他看起来有点像我父亲，但驼着背，好像世界都在压迫着他。他总是带着那种似乎在说“你在开玩笑吧”的表情。
You're keeping OK? You're keeping occupied?
你还好吗？你有事情做吗？
Yeah. I read a lot. I go to the gym. I go shopping, you know, here and there, little things here and there.
嗯。我读很多书。我去健身房。我去购物，你知道，这儿那儿的，零碎的小事。
And so you still go-- how often do you go to the gym?
那你还是会——你多久去一次健身房？
Three times a week.
一周三次。
My father also goes to the gym. That's a part of his routine also. He was happy to hear from you on his 80th birthday.
我父亲也去健身房。这也是他习惯的一部分。他在他80岁生日时很高兴接到你的电话。
Yeah. Well, he didn't call me on my 85th though.
嗯。好吧，他在我85岁生日时没打电话给我。
Tit, meet tat.
礼尚往来，见面谈吧。
To be honest with you, I've been-- in the last few years, I've been a loner.
老实跟你说，我一直是——在过去几年里，我一直是个独行侠。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
You would basically almost call me a recluse. I don't socialize with many people. And I really don't give a damn what anybody thinks.
你基本上可以叫我隐士。我不怎么和人交往。我真的不在乎别人怎么想。
Yeah.
嗯。
And contrary to popular belief, I like being alone by myself. I get along with myself very well.
而且与普遍观点相反，我喜欢独处。我自己一个人过得很好。
Yeah.
嗯。
Look, I don't want to be rude--
看，我不想无礼——
Yeah, yeah.
嗯，嗯。
--or anything, but I want to go have my lunch.
——或者什么的，但我想要去吃午饭了。
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. That's fine.
哦，是是是。那没关系。
Yeah.
嗯。
It's fine. Sheldon, I appreciate your talking to me. And you would be amenable to spending some time?
没关系。谢尔顿，谢谢你和我谈话。你愿意花点时间见见面吗？
Why not? We are brothers. I mean, we're not close or anything, but we're not going to have a chance to see each other much in the future.
为什么不呢？我们是兄弟。我是说，我们不亲近什么的，但在未来我们不会有多少机会见到彼此了。
Yeah. Is that anything that you think about?
嗯。那件事你考虑过吗？
Not much, no.
没怎么考虑，没有。
Press where to-- and then type-- you have an address?
按哪里来——然后输入——你有地址吗？
Yeah, I do.
有的，我有。
OK.
OK。
My dad and I meet up at the Fort Lauderdale Airport. I flew from New York and my dad from Montreal. My father's all dressed up, wearing a faux suede sports jacket that I've never seen him in. We grab our airport rental and prepare for the two-hour drive to Sheldon. In the 90-degree heat, it's immediately made clear that faux suede might not have been the best fashion choice.
我和爸爸在劳德代尔堡机场见面。我从纽约飞来，爸爸从蒙特利尔飞来。我父亲打扮得整整齐齐，穿着一件我从未见过的仿麂皮运动夹克。我们租了车，准备去谢尔顿那里进行两个小时的车程。在90度的炎热天气里，显而易见，仿麂皮可能不是最好的时尚选择。
It's like we're on a safari.
感觉我们像在进行狩猎旅行。
[CAR DOOR SHUTTING]
[车门关上声]
On the road to Sheldon's, my father will experience a spectrum of feelings. As we first set out, there's excitement.
在去往谢尔顿路上的过程中，父亲将经历一系列的情感波动。刚出发时，他很兴奋。
My brother was funny in a lot of ways. I could laugh. We're going to have laughs with him. You know what I mean? He's a very funny man.
我弟弟在很多方面都很有趣。我能笑得出来。我们会和他一起欢笑。你知道我的意思吗？他是个很有趣的人。
A half an hour in and there's bitterness.
半小时后，出现了苦涩。
We invited him to your bar mitzvah. And he returned a very cold card. Sorry, we will not be attending. It was so mean, you know what I mean, even the writing.
我们邀请他参加你的成年礼。他回了一张非常冷淡的卡片。对不起，我们不会参加。真的很刻薄，你明白我的意思吗，即使是上面的字迹。
An hour in and how is Buzz feeling?
一小时过去了，巴兹感觉如何？
I'm relaxed.
我很放松。
Oh, good.
哦，真好。
Kind of old to get anxious, you know what I mean?
年纪大了点，不会焦虑了，你明白我的意思吗？
Yeah.
嗯。
A half an hour to Sheldon's.
离谢尔顿那里还有半小时。
Little bit apprehensive now. [CHUCKLES]
现在有点不安了。[轻笑]
Yeah.
嗯。
10 minutes to Sheldon's and Buzz is feeling--
离谢尔顿那还有10分钟，巴兹感觉——
All right.
行吧。
Yeah? You feeling a little--
嗯？你感觉有点——
It's going to be strange.
会很奇怪。
Yeah.
嗯。
It's going to be very strange. I mean, the man is a stranger to me now, and yet he's my brother. You understand? It's a very strange feeling.
会非常奇怪。我是说，这个人现在对我来说是个陌生人，但他是我弟弟。你明白吗？那是一种非常奇怪的感觉。
Yeah.
嗯。
I wonder if he's getting nervous.
我想知道他是否也会紧张。
Maybe.
也许吧。
Course, he's waiting for us, right?
当然，他在等我们，对吧？
Yeah.
嗯。
Sheldon lives in the corner house on a quiet, suburban street.
谢尔顿住在一个安静的郊区街道尽头的房子里。
Ring the bell.
按门铃。
I guess. Is this his door?
应该是吧。这是他的门吗？
I'll double check. Oh, here he is.
我再确认一下。哦，他在这。
Ah.
啊。
Hey.
嘿。
Hello. Hi.
你好。嗨。
Good to see you.
很高兴见到你。
And this is Jonathan?
这就是乔纳森？
Good to see you, yeah.
很高兴见到你，是的。
Nice to meet you. Come in.
见到你很高兴。进来吧。
Come here.
过来吧。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Lately I've become a monk, me and my pussycat.
最近我变得像个僧侣，我和我的猫。
Oh, you got a cat.
哦，你养了猫。
Oh, come here. What?
哦，过来。什么？
[MEOWING]
[猫叫声]
[CHUCKLES]
[轻笑]
After all the years, and the worry, and the dread, things seem to be going swimmingly. We sit down at Sheldon's kitchen table, and my father gets right into it.
经过这么多年的担心和恐惧，事情似乎进行得非常顺利。我们坐在谢尔顿的厨房桌边，父亲直奔主题。
Now there's things I want to know. You said that Rainey died.
现在有些我想知道的事情。你说瑞妮去世了。
Yeah.
是的。
She did die?
她真的去世了吗？
The dead are a good place to begin. As a subject, they're easily agreed upon and not likely to spark a fight.
死者是一个很好的对话起点。作为一个主题，他们很容易达成共识，而且不太可能引发争吵。
Yankel died.
扬克尔去世了。
Yankel died? He was the youngest brother.
扬克尔去世了？他是最小的弟弟。
Oh, he died long ago.
哦，他很久以前就去世了。
He died, eh? Well, you know who died?
他去世了，嗯？那么，你知道谁去世了吗？
Who?
谁？
Hoffman.
霍夫曼。
Hoffman, a real [BLEEP].
霍夫曼，真是个[脏话]。
Yeah. I didn't know him that well. I didn't [BLEEP]. Yeah.
是的。我不太了解他。我没[脏话]。是啊。
Kanish. We used to [INAUDIBLE].
卡尼什。我们曾经[听不清]。
Oh, that's shocking.
哦，那太令人震惊了。
Yeah. He was fat.
是的。他很胖。
He was fat-- redhead.
他很胖——红头发。
Redhead, right.
红头发，对。
Yeah, Kanish. Yeah. Remember Johnny? Johnny was a sex maniac.
是的，卡尼什。没错。还记得乔尼吗？乔尼是个性狂。
Johnny, oh, he would [BLEEP] a dog on the street. If he saw the dog, he'd try to [BLEEP].
乔尼，哦，他会跟街上的狗[脏话]。如果他看到狗，他会尝试[脏话]。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Can I get you guys a cold beer?
我可以给你们拿点冰啤酒吗？
I'd like a beer.
我想要杯啤酒。
Yeah, sure. I'll have a beer.
好的，当然。我喝啤酒。
Even though they're in their 80s, Sheldon and Buzz still possess voices and temperaments suited to shouting out Brooklyn tenement windows, while my voice--
即使他们都80多岁了，谢尔顿和巴兹仍然拥有适合从布鲁克林的廉租房窗户大声叫喊的声音和脾气，而我的声音——
Yeah, sure. I'll have a beer.
好的，当然。我喝啤酒。
--is best suited to asking a waitress if there will be a sharing charge.
——最适合问服务员会不会收分享费。
I defy--
我拒绝——
[CLATTERING]
[叮当声]
[BLEEP]
[脏话]
Forgot about that. Sorry.
忘了那个。抱歉。
Case in point, this is Sheldon accidentally swiping a portable microphone receiver off the kitchen table and me trying to smooth things over.
例子就是，这是谢尔顿不小心把便携式麦克风接收器从餐桌上扫下去，我试图圆场。
Take this off, will you? It's annoying.
把它拿掉，好吗？真烦人。
Here, just put it in your pocket there.
给你，放进口袋里就行。
Just take it off, would you please? Thank you. Thank you.
就把它拿掉，拜托好吗？谢谢。谢谢。
Over the next two days, my testes will flee like frightened cockroaches upward, ascending to heights not seen since the bar mitzvah that Sheldon was not attending. While it's fun watching them reminisce, I'd say that about 80% of my Uncle Sheldon's stories about the good old days are filthy enough to make them virtually unbroadcastable. But here's one specially selected and beeped for your delicate ears.
接下来的两天里，我的睾丸会像受惊的蟑螂一样向上逃窜，升到谢尔顿没参加的那次成年礼之后就从未达到过的高度。虽然看着他们叙旧很有趣，但我得说，关于美好旧时光的谢尔顿叔叔的故事中，约80%的内容足以让它们变得实际上无法播出。但这是特别挑选并消音的一段，留给你们娇贵的耳朵。
Wally Rosen, wonder whatever became of him. He was a bum. Me and Wally Rosen were joining the weightlifting club. So you had to be tested for a rupture. I remember he put his hand [BLEEP]. I started laughing so hard I [BLEEP] right in his [BLEEP].
沃利·罗森，不知道他后来怎么样了。他是个流浪汉。我和沃利·罗森要加入举重俱乐部。所以你必须测试是否有疝气。我记得他把手放[脏话]。我开始大笑，笑得[脏话]直接拉在他[脏话]里了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Ay yi yi yi.
哎呀呀呀呀。
Over the years, I've seen my father in the role of husband, uncle, and grandfather, but I've never really seen him in the role of younger brother. How odd to see it now at 80. He sits beside Sheldon with this expression I've never seen on his face. It's wide-eyed, sweet, and deferential. But as the day wears on, Sheldon and Buzz begin to squabble over their memories, fighting over every little detail.
多年来，我见过我父亲扮演丈夫、叔叔和祖父的角色，但我从未真正见过他扮演弟弟的角色。在80岁时看到这一幕真是奇怪。他带着我从未见过的表情坐在谢尔顿身边。那是睁大眼睛、甜美而恭敬的表情。但随着一天过去，谢尔顿和巴兹开始为他们的记忆争吵，为每一个细节而争执。
Remember the hullabaloo we had with the hair dyer, that heavyset girl?
记得我们和那个染发师闹出的风波吗，那个壮实的女孩？
A manicurist.
是个美甲师。
She was a hair dyer.
她是染发师。
Manicurist.
美甲师。
No, she was a hair dyer. Here's what happened. She went over to Irving's--
不，她是染发师。事情是这样的。她去了欧文家——
They even argue over the death of their grandmother.
他们甚至为祖母的去世而争论。
I found her body.
是我发现她遗体的。
I did.
是我。
I opened the door-- no.
我打开门——不。
I did.
是我。
My mother was across the street at Greenberg's.
我母亲当时在格林伯格家对面。
I remember walking in--
我记得我走进去——
I looked in on her.
我进去看她——
--and I knew she was dead as soon as I saw her.
——我一看到她就知道她死了。
I never saw a dead body in my life, but I knew she was dead. Sure.
我这辈子没见过死人，但我知道她死了。没错。
So, wait. So you found her, or you found her?
等等。所以是你发现了她，还是你发现了她？
I remember looking in on her room.
我记得我进去看了看她的房间。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉对话]
It was awfully quiet.
太安静了。
I found her, but let him take the credit.
是我发现的，但让把功劳归他吧。
No, I'm not--
不，我没——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Some credit.
算什么功劳。
The whole afternoon is like this. Every subject, even their dead grandmother, somehow becomes fodder for another pissing match. They're burning up all this time with small talk when what they need is some big talk. In particular, they need to address a story that I know holds a great deal of meaning for my father. It took place in 1939 on the day their mother left them. I've only ever heard the story from my father, never from Sheldon.
整个下午都是这样。每个主题，即使是他们的亡祖母，不知何故都成了另一场比拼尿远的游戏的素材。他们浪费了所有时间在闲聊上，而他们需要的是一些真正的交谈。特别是，他们需要谈论一个我父亲认为意义重大的故事。它发生在1939年他们母亲离开的那一天。我只从父亲那里听到过这个故事，从未从谢尔顿那里听到过。
I wanted to ask what you remember, your perspective.
我想问你还记得什么，你的视角。
Well, I remember that time was when Pop was smacking her around, and she ran out in the hall in her slip.
嗯，我记得当时爸爸在打她，她只穿着衬裙跑到了大厅里。
Fighting in the hall.
在大厅里打架。
No. He was smacking her around.
不。他在打她。
Smacking her around, yeah.
在打她，没错。
She ran out.
她跑了出去。
Yeah. So what happened the next morning?
是的。那第二天早上发生了什么？
The next morning?
第二天早上？
Yeah. Look in the closet. Her clothes were gone. She left.
嗯。看壁橱。她的衣服都没了。她离开了。
Oh.
哦。
What happened after this, in my father's telling, is that his mother returned soon after she left with a policeman in tow.
在这之后发生了什么，在我父亲的叙述中，是他的母亲在离开后不久带着一名警察回来了。
And they came back to try to get you. They wanted you to come back with them.
他们回来想带你走。他们想让你和他们一起回去。
And where were you?
那你当时在哪？
I was there. They were trying to drag you out of the house. [LAUGHS]
我在那。他们想把你从屋里拖走。[笑]
They weren't trying to grab you out?
他们不是想把你抢走吗？
No, no, no. I could stay with my father and grandmother.
不，不，不。我可以和父亲、祖母待在一起。
This is the point of the story for my father. It proves once and for all how his mother loved Sheldon more than she loved him. Sheldon didn't move out with her. And after a year, their mother returned. And together Buzz and Sheldon grew up under the same roof, in the same bedroom, often sleeping under the same blanket, each knowing who the mother had chosen, and each having to do their best to carry on and live life with the burden of that knowledge.
这就是我父亲讲述故事的重点。它一劳永逸地证明了母亲爱谢尔顿胜过爱他。谢尔顿没跟她搬走。一年后，他们的母亲回来了。巴兹和谢尔顿一起在同一个屋檐下、同一个卧室里长大，经常睡在同一条毯子下，每个人都知道母亲选择了谁，每个人都必须尽力背负着这种知识的负担继续生活下去。
A couple times during the day, I asked them why they haven't spoken in so long. And they both insist, maybe out of embarrassment, that they do talk, just not often. But it isn't true.
一天里我问过他们几次为什么这么久没说话。他们可能出于尴尬都坚持说他们确实会交流，只是不常交流。但这并不是事实。
In fact, my father learned of Sheldon's wife's death many years after the fact and then only from me. Sheldon's daughter got in touch through Facebook, and we made a phone date where she caught me up on her life and Sheldon's. And a few nights later while over at my parents' for dinner, I told my father of his sister-in-law's death. There was a terrible look that fell across his face, one of sadness, but something else too, maybe shock over just how far he and Sheldon had drifted.
事实上，我父亲在谢尔顿妻子去世多年后才从我这里得知。谢尔顿的女儿通过Facebook联系我，我们定了个通话时间，她跟我谈了她和谢尔顿的生活。几天后我在父母家吃晚饭时，告诉父亲他弟媳去世的消息。他脸上出现了一种可怕的表情，一种悲伤，但还有别的什么，也许是对他和谢尔顿竟然疏远到这种地步的震惊。
I found out about Judy, about her death.
我发现了朱迪的事，关于她去世的事。
Who?
谁？
Your wife.
你妻子。
I didn't know about it either until you told me.
我也是你告诉我才知道的。
Yeah.
嗯。
Didn't I tell you?
我没告诉你吗？
No.
没。
You didn't know about it?
你不知道吗？
We didn't know. We didn't know.
我们不知道。我们不知道。
She was sick about two years, Judy. Well, when she got the diagnosis, she was already stage four. What did I know about cancer? So the surgeon-- so I said, well, doc, how did the surgery go? Oh, he said, it went very well. But the cancer's in her liver now.
朱迪生病了大概两年。嗯，当她得到诊断时，已经是第四期了。我对癌症了解什么？所以医生——我说，医生，手术怎么样？哦，他说，进行得非常好。但癌症现在在她的肝脏里。
Oh. It spread.
哦。扩散了。
I said, it's in her liver? I said, what?
我说，在她的肝脏里？我说，什么？
You know where I usually eat when I come in by myself? By the bar. They've got a waitress there who always waits on me. She takes good care of me.
你知道我通常一个人进来时在哪里吃饭吗？在酒吧。那里有个女招待总是招待我。她很照顾我。
For dinner, Sheldon takes us to a local Outback Steakhouse. As people walk by, he provides a running commentary of an elderly couple--
晚餐时，谢尔顿带我们去了一家当地的Outback牛排馆。当人们走过时，他提供了对一对老年夫妇的实况解说——
Don't get like that couple, whatever you do. It's time for the execution.
不管怎么样，别变得像那对夫妇那样。死刑时间到了。
--of an overweight couple.
——对一对超重夫妇。
Boy, are they fat. People are fat today.
天哪，他们真胖。今天的人真胖。
It's as though he's sharpening his wit, readying it for the main event, teasing my dad about Canada.
就好像他在磨练自己的智慧，为重头戏做准备，打趣我爸爸关于加拿大的事。
I don't know how you could take Canada all year round.
我不明白你怎么能整年忍受加拿大。
Why? We've got nice neighbors. It's nice. It's OK. What was I going to say?
为什么？我们有好邻居。很好。还行。我刚想说什么来着？
You're living in the same place for how many years?
你在同一个地方住了多少年了？
Oh, about-- over 35, 38 years, something like that. I'm happy there. Yeah, yeah.
哦，大概——超过35、38年之类的吧。我住在那里很开心。是的，是的。
For my father, I know this is a touchy subject, believing, as he always has, that Sheldon looks down on him for the dinkiness of his Canadian life and home. It's like a constant reminder of just who is second best. Later, my father will repeat Sheldon's words. You're still living in that same place, he'll say, for how many years? But just then, I watched my father clench and unclench his jaw, as he does when he is brooding. I know he's trying to take the high road, trying not to ruin the evening.
对我父亲来说，我知道这是一个敏感话题，他一直认为谢尔顿因为他平庸的加拿大生活和住所而看不起他。这就像时刻提醒他谁才是第二名。后来，我父亲会重复谢尔顿的话。“你还在住那个地方，”他会说，“多少年了？”但就在那时，我看着父亲紧咬着牙关，就像他心事重重时那样。我知道他在试图保持高姿态，尽量不破坏气氛。
What, $200.30? Are they kidding?
什么，200.30美元？开玩笑吗？
Sheldon invites us back to his place for cookies, but my father says he isn't up for it.
谢尔顿邀请我们去他家吃饼干，但我父亲说他没那个精神。
Thank you. Good night.
谢谢。晚安。
Yep.
没错。
As we walk through the restaurant parking lot to the car, my father is silent. I find myself feeling protective of him, like maybe encouraging this trip had been a bad idea, only making things worse. After midnight, lying awake in our hotel-- my father insisted we stay at one-- I lay in bed thinking about that day in 1939 when my grandmother came back for Sheldon, not my father. For my father, not only did it push him away from Sheldon, making him feel jealous and resentful, but it also cast a shadow over the rest of his life, causing him to always feel passed over. He's mellowed with age, but as a kid I saw it come out in all kinds of ways-- always sensitive to slights, ready for a fight at the smallest perceived offense.
当我们走过餐馆停车场去车边时，父亲沉默了。我发现自己开始保护他，觉得鼓励这次旅行可能是一个糟糕的主意，只会让事情变得更糟。半夜，躺在旅馆里——父亲坚持我们住在那里——我躺在床上想着1939年的那一天，祖母回来接谢尔顿而不是父亲。对我父亲来说，这不仅把他推离了谢尔顿，让他感到嫉妒和怨恨，还在他余生的心头投下了阴影，使他总是觉得自己被忽视。他随年龄增长变得圆滑了一些，但小时候我看到它以各种方式表现出来——总是对冷落敏感，准备为最小的冒犯而争吵。
I wonder if there's a different way for my father to see things. If there is, the only living person in this world who can help is Sheldon. When their mom left, Sheldon was nine, my father five. Sheldon would have understood a lot more than my father.
我想知道是否有另一种方式能让父亲看待事物。如果有，世界上唯一能帮忙的人就是谢尔顿。母亲离开时，谢尔顿9岁，我父亲5岁。谢尔顿理解的东西比父亲多得多。
Yesterday, Buzz and Sheldon talked like a couple of kids who used to play stickball in the old neighborhood. Today, if me and my big fat meddling yap have any sway, they'll have a chance to talk as men, as brothers even. Because if not now, when? Day two.
昨天，巴兹和谢尔顿像两个在旧街区玩拍球的孩子一样交谈。今天，如果我和我那张爱管闲事的大嘴巴有任何影响力，他们将有机会作为男人，甚至作为兄弟谈谈。因为如果不是现在，那是何时？第二天。
This is a damn good cigar.
这雪茄真不错。
He sent me--
他送我——
Oh, Dominican Republic. They make a damn good cigar in Dominican Republic. What are you talking about?
哦，多米尼加共和国。他们在多米尼加共和国做的雪茄真不错。你在说什么呢？
Despite the difficulties of last night, the coin is flipped back to the good side. Sheldon offers my father a cigar and with the cigar some cigar talk, some pretty foul cigar talk.
尽管昨晚有困难，但硬币又翻回了好的一面。谢尔顿给了父亲一支雪茄，还谈论了一些雪茄话题，一些非常粗俗的雪茄话题。
We're riding on Queens Boulevard. Johnny's in the back seat with The Who. He's got his naked ass up in the air. And he's humping--
我们在皇后大道上骑行。乔尼在后座和The Who在一起。他光着屁股在空中。他在做活塞运动——
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
The funny thing is we had to stop for a light. And there's a truck driver sitting in the cab up high. God, that was funny.
有趣的是我们必须在红绿灯处停下。有个卡车司机坐在高高的驾驶室里。天哪，那太好笑了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Have you guys missed each other?
你们想念彼此吗？
What?
什么？
Do you miss each other?
你们想念彼此吗？
You know, he asks the weirdest questions. What is he, a broad?
你知道，他总是问些最奇怪的问题。他是娘们儿吗？
No. I mean-- I don't know.
不。我是说——我不知道。
Eager to prove to my Uncle Sheldon that in spite of the fact I'm wearing my wife's travel deodorant, I am indeed not a broad. I allow them to return to more pressing matters, their prostates.
急于向谢尔顿叔叔证明，尽管我穿着妻子的旅行除臭剂，但我确实不是娘们儿。我让他们回归到更紧迫的问题上，他们的前列腺。
The guy says, Jesus. He says, your prostate feels like the moon craters in there. I said thank you, Doctor. Thought he was complimenting me.
那家伙说，天哪。他说，你的前列腺摸起来像里面的月球陨石坑。我说谢谢，医生。以为他在赞美我。
So if I could steer this away from the prostates-- so my father said that it's significant to him to have come. What do you say?
如果我能把话题从前列腺上引开——我父亲说这次来对他很重要。你觉得呢？
I agree with whatever he said.
他说的什么我同意什么。
But what about you?
那你是怎么想的？
I said I agree with whatever he said. Do you want a written contract?
我说他说的什么我同意什么。你想要一份书面合同吗？
No, no. I'm happy with that.
不，不。我对此很高兴。
It feels like I'm getting a taste of what growing up with Sheldon might have been like. So again, I make my move.
感觉我像是在品尝和谢尔顿一起长大的感觉。所以我再次行动。
So I have some questions just about-- because of the stories that I know from my father, but I'm curious what your take is because you were older. Do you remember what was going on when your mom-- when your mother left originally, like why and what was going on?
我有几个问题想问，因为我从父亲那里知道这些故事，但我好奇你的看法，因为你年纪大。你还记得你妈妈当初离开时发生了什么吗，为什么以及当时发生了什么？
Didn't you cover this ground before yesterday?
昨天不是谈过这些了吗？
But from my father's perspective, the way I understood it was always you were the favorite. Did you feel that way?
但从我父亲的角度来看，我的理解一直是你最受宠。你有这种感觉吗？
At this point, Sheldon's face suddenly softens.
此时，谢尔顿的脸突然柔和下来。
I always felt that I got the short end of the stick.
我一直觉得我处境最糟。
Yeah, but you were kind of a favorite with my mom.
是，但你确实挺受我妈喜欢的。
Yeah, maybe with Mom 'cause maybe temperamentally we were closer than I was with my father. My father never gave me spit. Did you ever get any money from my father?
是，可能和妈在一起是因为性格上我们可能比我和父亲更近。父亲从来没给过我什么。你从父亲那里拿到过钱吗？
Can't remember.
记不得了。
You never got a dime.
你从来没拿到过一毛钱。
No, can't remember.
不，记不得了。
You never-- one time I sprained my ankle so bad.
你从来——有一次我脚踝扭得特别厉害。
Oh, I'll never forget that. That was terrible.
哦，我永远不会忘记那个。那太可怕了。
I laid in that bed. And he says to me, you lazy bum.
我躺在床上。他跟我说，你个懒流浪汉。
Yeah.
是啊。
Man, he went off on me that time. Whoo.
天哪，那次他对我发了火。哇。
He took Sheldon once. Sheldon happened to say the word [BLEEP].
他带谢尔顿去过一次。谢尔顿碰巧说了个[脏话]词。
He came in with that [BLEEP] strap swinging with the buckle.
他带着那个[脏话]带着扣子的带子挥舞着进来了。
And I can understand it leaving a feeling of resentment and dislike.
我可以理解那会留下一种怨恨和厌恶的感觉。
That was his way of communicating with us-- smack, smack, and then--
那是他与我们交流的方式——啪啪，然后——
What a way. Yeah.
真是个好方法。是啊。
Was he easier on you, do you think?
你认为他对你更宽容吗？
He wasn't that easy, but he was tough on Sheldon.
他没那么宽容，但他对谢尔顿很严厉。
I know you were closer to him than I was.
我知道你比我更接近他。
Yeah.
是的。
A lot of things that went on and you didn't understand really what was going on.
发生了很多事情，而你并没有真正理解发生了什么。
No, I didn't. So you had a different take?
不，我没懂。所以你有不同的看法？
Why? Are you surprised by--
怎么？你对——感到惊讶吗？
But I was a kid. I didn't understand it.
但我当时是个孩子。我不明白。
But you didn't know that Sheldon was getting it so bad?
但你不知道谢尔顿受了这么多苦？
No.
不。
In Buzz's telling, their father was always a more or less benign, childish figure incapable of expressing his feelings and so given to temper tantrums. For Buzz, it was their mother who was the manipulator, the woman who played the brothers off each other. But hearing Sheldon's take, it sounds like maybe their mother didn't come to take Sheldon because she loved him best, but simply because he needed more protecting from their father.
在巴兹的叙述中，他们的父亲一直是个或多或少良性、幼稚的人物，无法表达自己的情感，因此容易发脾气。对巴兹来说，是母亲才是操纵者，是那个让兄弟反目的女人。但听了谢尔顿的说法，听起来母亲当初不来接谢尔顿并不是因为最爱他，而仅仅是因为他需要更多来自父亲的保护。
For the first time during our trip, I can see my father considering Sheldon's point of view, actually taking it in. I know it's intense for him because he can't even meet Sheldon's eyes. Instead, he looks at me, addresses his comments to me.
这是我们旅行中第一次，我看到父亲在考虑谢尔顿的观点，真的听进去了。我知道这对他来说很强烈，因为他甚至无法直视谢尔顿的眼睛。相反，他看着我，向我发表评论。
It sad that my father had such a negative impact on him, just awful. Because he had so much going for him. He was a wonderful son. He worked hard. He was a good boy. He went to school.
悲哀的是，我父亲对他有如此负面的影响，太可怕了。因为他本来有很多优点。他是个好儿子。他工作努力。他是个好孩子。他上了学。
You're talking like I'm a failure in life.
你说的好像我是个失败者。
No, you weren't a failure. That's the thing that I'm saying.
不，你不是失败者。这就是我说的重点。
No, I am.
不，我是。
You weren't a failure. But all I'm saying is that emotionally he left an impact on you.
你不是失败者。我只是说他在情感上对你留下了影响。
It took a long time for me to get out of that emotion. And now I'm at peace with myself. I can talk about him and laugh about it.
我花了好长时间才从那种情绪中走出来。现在我对自己感到平静。我可以谈论他并以此为乐。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊。
Now I want peace, quiet. I'm happy living by myself.
现在我想要和平，安静。我一个人住很开心。
Are you lonely, Sheldon?
谢尔顿，你寂寞吗？
No.
不。
No?
不？
The last time my father saw my grandfather in full health, my dad was visiting from Canada. My grandfather asked my father to drive him to the cemetery to visit his parents' grave. And once there, my grandfather wept inconsolably. Later that day, he would succumb to a stroke and shortly after be moved to a nursing home. With Sheldon being more local, the burden of my grandfather's care fell mainly to Sheldon. It seems like a lot of the family's burdens fell to Sheldon.
父亲最后一次见到祖父完全健康时，父亲正在从加拿大来探访。祖父请父亲开车带他去墓地探望他父母的墓。到了那里，祖父伤心地哭了起来。那天晚些时候，他中风了，不久后被送进疗养院。由于谢尔顿住得近，照顾祖父的重担主要落在了谢尔顿身上。似乎家庭的很多负担都落在了谢尔顿肩上。
They put a lot of the responsibility on him that my dad should have been taking that responsibility. And he shouldered that.
他们把很多责任都推给他，而原本我爸应该承担这些责任。他承担下来了。
Who was going to take care of you? Who was going to take you to school? [INAUDIBLE] I remember one time I was late or something. You stood outside that screen door, crying.
谁来照顾你？谁来送你上学？[听不清]我记得有一次我迟到了什么的。你站在纱门外面哭。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊。
I'd say, Buzzy, I'm here. I'm here.
我会说，巴兹，我在这。我在这。
He was good to me. A lot of times he was good to me.
他对我很好。很多时候他对我很好。
A lot of times I was mean to you.
很多时候我对你很刻薄。
Mean, you know-- you were my older brother. You used to knock the [BLEEP] out of me sometimes, but that's the way it is with brothers. Yeah.
刻薄，你知道——你是哥哥。有时候你确实把我[脏话]揍了一顿，但兄弟之间就是这样。是的。
I was good in some ways. Some ways I was mean.
在某些方面我很好。在某些方面我很刻薄。
Well, who is not? Who is not? Who is not?
嗯，谁不是呢？谁不是呢？谁不是呢？
So if you feel like you were compelled to see each other now because you knew that it's a now or never kind of thing, then it means that it was important to you both, right, to see each other.
所以如果你觉得你们现在必须见到对方，因为你们知道这是最后的机会，那意味着你们两个都认为见到对方很重要，对吧？
You want to take that?
你要回答吗？
Sure.
当然。
I'm not. Go ahead.
我不想。你说吧。
Yes. It's an easy answer-- yes. Yes, because we're not getting any younger. What's down the road? I'm 80. He's 85.
是的。答案很简单——是的。是的，因为我们都在变老。未来会怎样？我80岁了。他85岁了。
I mean, because there was a lot of water under the bridge, and we want to close that bridge now. I want to feel easy now. I want to say now he's going to be 86, I want to call him on his birthday and say happy birthday to him now. I'm not going to stand any [BLEEP] ceremonies anymore.
我是说，因为覆水难收，我们现在想结束那道桥了。我想现在感到轻松。我想现在他要86岁了，我打电话给他说生日快乐。我再也不想搞什么[脏话]仪式了。
As my father speaks, as per his brother's example, dropping F bombs like he's in a Guy Ritchie film, Sheldon keeps his arms crossed and his eyes shut tight. He's quiet for several seconds, and then he reaches out to pet his cat.
随着父亲说话，正如他弟弟的榜样一样，像在盖·里奇的电影里那样骂着粗口，谢尔顿双臂交叉，双眼紧闭。他安静了几秒钟，然后伸手去抚摸他的猫。
Should I leave you the cat in my will if anything happens?
如果发生什么事，我该把猫留给你吗？
If anything happens, I'll take care of the cat. I'll take care of the cat.
如果发生什么事，我会照顾这只猫。我会照顾这只猫的。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
I'm happy I came to see you. That I am.
我很高兴来见你。真的。
I'm happy you came here. That's good, very good. If either of you want to buy a house, that one is for sale over there.
我很高兴你来这里。那很好，非常好。如果你们谁想买房子，那边那栋正在出售。
When it's time to leave, Sheldon walks us outside. But before we get into the rental, he points across the lawn to his neighbor's house. He tells my father that it's for sale, and then he tells him the asking price. And my father says that doesn't sound bad at all. And Sheldon says that, what, with Canada being so bloody cold, my father should consider moving to Florida. And my father says maybe he will.
是时候离开时，谢尔顿送我们出去。但在我们坐进租的车之前，他指向草坪对面邻居的房子。他告诉我父亲房子正在出售，然后报出了要价。我父亲说听起来还不错。谢尔顿说，加拿大天气这么冷，父亲应该考虑搬到佛罗里达。我父亲说也许他会。
All right. You take care.
好吧。保重。
Water under the bridge.
覆水难收。
Take care.
保重。
Take care, you too. Safe trip, both of yous.
你也保重。旅途平安，你们两个。
Thank you, thank you. We'll speak. We'll speak.
谢谢，谢谢。我们会保持联系。会保持联系的。
They don't get too emotional. They don't even hug goodbye. They just shake hands. And with that, it feels like Buzz has forgiven Sheldon and Sheldon has forgiven Buzz.
他们没有表现得太情绪化。他们甚至没有拥抱告别。他们只是握了握手。这样，感觉巴兹原谅了谢尔顿，谢尔顿也原谅了巴兹。
Turn right on Northwest Bedford Drive.
在西北贝德福德大道右转。
Oh my god. I feel so different now, you know that? I feel different, Johnny. I just feel so different. This has taken a lot off my shoulders, you know?
天哪。我现在感觉太不一样了，你知道吗？我感觉不一样，乔尼。我感觉太不一样了。这让我肩上的担子减轻了很多，你知道吗？
Jonathan Goldstein. This story was produced by Wendy Dorr with some help from Chris Neary for Jonathan's podcast, Heavyweight. If you have never heard Heavyweight and don't know where to get started, I have to say, it is such an utterly original program. And Jonathan has put together a playlist of his favorite episodes. Just search Heavyweight Starter Kit on Spotify. Jonathan, by the way, says his dad and Sheldon are doing fine under lockdown. Sheldon says that he's happy with the peace and quiet.
乔纳森·戈尔茨坦。这个故事是由温蒂·多尔制作的，并得到了克里斯·尼里的帮助，用于乔纳森的播客《重磅人物》。如果你从没听过《重磅人物》，不知道从哪里开始，我不得不说，这确实是一个非常原创的节目。乔纳森汇总了他最喜欢的剧集播放列表。只需在Spotify上搜索“重磅人物入门套件”。乔纳森说，他的父亲和谢尔顿在封锁期间过得不错。谢尔顿说他对自己享受和平与宁静感到很高兴。
[MUSIC - THE BAMBOOS, "BEFORE I GO"]
[音乐 - THE BAMBOOS, "BEFORE I GO"]
(SINGING) I still wonder how we got to this, how we pretend not to notice.
(歌唱) 我仍然想知道我们是怎么走到这一步的，我们怎么假装没注意到。
When today's program was first broadcast four years ago, produced by Robyn Semien. Our staff for this episode-- Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Dan Chivvis, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe Walt, David Kestenbaum, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Production help for this rerun from Noor Gill, Katherine Rae Mondo, and Stowe Nelson. Our translator for the wind phone was Kiku Matsuo. Special thanks today to Emily Engle-Young, Brittany [INAUDIBLE], Dragana Novakovic, Helen Garey, Yuki Zaizen, Noriko Meek, Karin Jeffrey, John Matthews, Christine Fellows, Haley Shaw, and Lawrence Tassone.
今天的节目首次播出是在四年前，由罗宾·塞米恩制作。本期的全体员工——埃尔娜·贝克、苏珊·伯顿、佐伊·蔡斯、丹·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德拉明、凯伦·达芬、伊曼纽尔·佐齐、斯蒂芬妮·富、查娜·乔菲·沃尔特、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和南希·厄普代克。重播的生产帮助来自努尔·吉尔、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多和斯托·尼尔森。我们的风之电话翻译是松尾菊。今天特别感谢艾米莉·恩格尔-杨、布列塔尼[听不清]、德拉加纳·诺瓦科维奇、海伦·加里、由纪财前、纪子米克、卡琳·杰弗里、约翰·马修斯、克里斯汀·费洛斯、海莉·肖和劳伦斯·塔索内。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where during lockdown or during your commute to your essential job you can listen to 700 episodes of our show for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. Presidential debates are coming up later this year. He tells everybody he knows why I'm never chosen to ask questions at the presidential debates.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在封锁期间或通勤去从事必要工作时，你可以完全免费收听我们节目的700集。《美国生活》通过PRX公共广播交易提供给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。总统辩论将在今年晚些时候举行。他告诉他认识的每个人为什么我从来没被选去在总统辩论中提问。
You know, he asks the weirdest questions.
你知道，他总是问些最奇怪的问题。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - THE BAMBOOS, "BEFORE I GO"]
[音乐 - THE BAMBOOS, "BEFORE I GO"]
(SINGING) Before I go, before I go, before I go. Before I go, before I go, before I go.
(歌唱) 在我走之前，在我走之前，在我走之前。在我走之前，在我走之前，在我走之前。